- Alright, I gotta
do this interview.
I love you, see you.
Super excited about
today's DailyVee.
Pretty interesting day, I was
looking at the schedule,
there's not a lot of
places you can go today.
I've got, they're not letting
you go to that three hour
advertising counsel,--
- [DRock] No.
- I got an advertising, I'm on
the ad counsel and there's this
client meeting now (censored).
That's not happening.
You know what I feel?
I feel an epic rant.
I feel like I have
to do a fucking rant.
So, I'm in good spirits.
We'll see what happens today.
I can't figure out what though.
I know where this is going.
I'll see you.
I don't give a fuck if you
think I'm the greatest and
fucking the Messiah or
if you think I'm a
piece of shit con artist,
I'll see you.
("Summerbreeze" by Jura Kez)
What I did well, Kelly, is
that I figured out what I had to
do which was I needed to be
accountable to somebody
else besides myself.
If I can think of anything to
anybody listening right now,
I genuinely believe
this is a binary game.
Either you keep yourself
accountable or you're going to
be accountable to somebody else.
I think a lot of people that
struggle with fitness and health
and fitness and really probably
in life in general in different
disciplines is they're unable
to be accountable to themselves.
And honestly, the reason I think
I'm good at business is because
I'm accountable to other people.
If you think about my life,
I went right into my
family business.
I was doing it for my family
and then I was doing it for my
brother then I'm, now even my,
you know, back to Ustream,
I was doing it for you.
Even now with the,
I'm doing it for them.
I'm always doing it for somebody
else, that's my natural state.
I even see it in
my two children.
That's how my little
guy Xander's going to be.
He thinks about his
sister first, then himself.
It's just my default and so but
in health there was nobody else
to do it for so I figured out
that I needed a full-time health
person, that was not my
full-time trainer, that was like
full-time health person meaning
they've only worked for me.
Period, end of story.
That I would make that big
financial commitment and
that I would be
accountable to that person.
So I called Mike, I said,
do you know somebody and
he said I would do it.
I go whoa, you're gonna
give up all your other stuff.
He's like yeah, it's worth it.
I want to build an
online business.
I'll do it with you and
so that's what started.
No alternative.
Here's the punchline,
you know I love when people,
I don't care what you think,
whether you think
I'm right or I'm wrong.
All of this advice is only
what's, you know, first of all,
you need to know yourself.
This is what works for me.
I only want people
to use me as a proxy.
You don't have to do it my way.
Do you.
My definition of
an entrepreneur,
my definition of doing it right,
my definition of legacy,
it's my definition but
here's the punchline,
nobody's gonna
feel sorry for you.
Who's gonna feel sorry for you?
You, I'll tell you who's
gonna feel sorry for you.
Oh, you know who
feels sorry for you?
Your other enabling
losing players around you.
It's just one
fucking losing circle.
I mean either you're hanging out
with people that are dragging
you down or you're hang out with
people that are lifting you up
but I promise you this,
every winner in your life
has zero sympathy for you.
You know, I mean I don't know
what everybody, you're gonna be
90 and you're gonna
look back and what?
Like what?
This is it.
I mean there's just
so much complaining.
There's so much cynicism.
There's so much you got lucky.
There's so much.
Everybody just wants to
point at other people.
Point at your fucking self.
It's funny, Kel, I don't know if
you've been paying attention but
I've been very hot on
self-awareness for the last year
and I've been talking a lot
about it but it's funny and
I am feeling in my soul right
now I'm really going to start,
I can feel it emerging, we need
to talk more about the people
people surround themselves with.
It's a big one and you
know where I'm seeing it?
I'm seeing it around my people.
I'm seeing around my
team like it's so crazy.
When I think about Nate,
my former, and Phil and DRock
even like I've thrown
this out in the past.
It's fun for me to watch them go
from whatever they are to over a
period of time more confident,
more accountable,
harder working.
Even with some of them,
they start to become a little
cocky and I start laughing.
It really, it really matters.
I'm not worried about
anybody buying anything.
I know what I'm doing here
and my purpose is very simple.
I'm capable of making tons
of money building businesses.
I don't need, I don't need
the personal brand part of it.
I need people to start
doing shit and sending emails.
You know what I need?
I need the way you started this
show which is my work on social
media seven years ago inspired
you to do shit and your life is
better because of it.
Talk soon, bye-bye.
Yeah, I mean you know
before I go into this next call,
which is right now,
it's all talk.
I don't care what I say and
I don't care what
comments you're leaving.
At the end at the, I don't know
what I'm doing, at end of the
day, it's going to be
what it's going to be.
It all comes down to
20, 30, 40 years from.
Like what?
Like whether you're vlogging
everyday, whether nobody knows
who you are 'cause you're in
your home and you don't say a
single thing on
social, it's just results.
How do the people are
you feel about you?
How much did you create?
What impact did
you have on people?
What impact did you have
in yourself, your family?
It's all these things.
Work-life balance, financial,
I love when people
just take micro-shots,
let me just wrap it
up for you all here.
It's all of it.
It's the money, it's the fame,
it's the impact
you've had on people,
it's the way your
family thinks about you,
best friends think about you,
it's your non-profit work,
it's the legacy
you left on others,
it's how you inspired people,
it's how did you
make yourself feel,
it's what did you accomplish,
it's all of it.
Legacy is all encompassing.
It's not just how much money,
my legacy is not that I made a
lot of money and
bought the Jets.
My legacy is that unlike every
other business person I know
today, I'm gonna do that and I'm
gonna impact tens of millions of
people to have a better life
than they would've had,
had they not crossed my path.
What do you think about that?
Both.
You can have both.
You can be a fucking
ninja entrepreneur,
fucking hard core capitalist
and build fucking,
the fucking biggest business in
the world and you can be awesome
person and give back to society
at scale for the people
that don't have it as easy.
You can inspire them, you can
give them, you can help them.
You can do both if
you've got the talent.
What the fuck do you
guys think is happening here?
I can do both.
Both. You know?
I just don't
understand what people think.
You know?
- [DRock] They're all (inaudible).
- It's not even that.
It's just like both.
I'm gonna do it all.
I don't care what you
think I'm gonna do or not.
I get that you're
seeing one video
and you think
I'm all about, like you know,
like one person asked that
question like how
do you measure?
I'm like money.
That was in the context of
business in that one second.
You don't see,
you don't see me at the
non-profit conferences
and things like that.
You don't see what I do for
my friends behind the scenes.
You don't see how
I'm raising my children.
You don't see, I get it,
I get it but I'll see you.
I know where this is going.
I'll see you.
Like I don't give a fuck if
you think I'm the greatest
and fucking the Messiah or
if you think I'm a piece of shit
con artist, I'll see you.
I'll fucking see you.
I'll see you in
2020, 2030, 2040, 2050.
Everybody thought I was
just a fucking wine retailer.
Then I was just Twitter Boy.
Then I was this,
like I'll see you.
It doesn't matter
what we think today.
Matters what everybody
thinks when it's over.
I plan on fucking winning.
Straight up.
With your support
or your disdain.
I'm gonna fucking win.
That's it.
'Cause I'm gonna do both.
So I'm appease you,
capitalists and fuckin'
non-profitists and
fuckin' Team Human
and Team Business.
Republicans and Democrats,
fucking winners and losers.
I'm gonna appease
all you fuckers.
- [DRock] That was a good one.
- Hey, it's Gary.
("Victory" by OCD Mosh &amp; Twist)
- [Gary] Hello.
Hello, Ryan.
Yeah, I got it up
to (censored), yep.
Sleep.
This is a good opportunity in
the middle of this episode to,
or beginning or I don't know how
the fuck you guys edit, but this
whole me ranting with you guys
of like how much motivation
do you want?
Don't watch me.
I just want to give
some clarity on it.
It's much more theoretical
meaning I know some people
watch 'cause it's
entertaining or it's fun
or it's your escapism.
I watch the Jets.
We all have that.
It's, I just want
it so bad for you.
I want it bad for you.
You have to understand, unlike
so many people that look like
me, put out content, self
absorbed, vanity, all those
cliché things, I know how to
make money outside of you.
Unlike so many of the
gurus and the experts,
I don't make my living off
extracting money out of you.
You've gotta wrap
your head around this.
My currency, my pay off, my nut
that I'm trying to get off here
is the email from you that
I was the one that brought you
the value that got you to do
something good so when I'm
frustrated and I'm telling you
not to watch any more and go do,
think about how different that
is than everybody who's like,
"I'm not going to
give you anything.
"Oh, I'm gonna give you little
crumbs here and bah, look over
"here, pay me $40,000 a year
to get the real good stuff."
I want none of that.
I want the reverse.
I'm the reverse.
Of course, I want you to watch.
I'm thrilled that it's
escapism for you guys.
I have it too.
I love it, your
comments, I love it.
I read every one of your YouTube
things and your Facebook things.
Things? Comments.
You know like I love that.
But what I love more,
if I had to choose,
for as much as
I need the attention and
I starve for it and
I love the interaction
and selfies.
If I had to pick one, push comes
to shove, 51 to 49, I'd rather
you go away and have the
greatest life ever and send me
email in three years saying,
it was this video, that video,
that talk, that book
that brought you value.
That's real legacy.
That's way more noble.
I'm gonna get mine.
I was getting mine before
this all started, remember?
So that's the clarity
of stop watching me.
It's watch me because I love it
too but not at the expense of
getting what you deserve,
getting the most
out of life for you,
you winning in a world
where I know so many of you
aren't as fortunate as I was
to have people around you that
believed in you like
my mom and my friends,
I want to be that for you.
I want to be your
fucking cheerleader.
I believe that you can.
And by the way, not,
I'm not like anybody can
do it, some you suck.
Some of you don't
have the skills.
Why do you think I talk about
self-awareness and the reality
of, I talk about self-awareness,
the reality of hard work and
talent being a real variable.
I'm not some
fucking, anybody can do it.
I hate fifth place trophies.
I just want you to try hard at
the thing that you may naturally
be best at because that's where
everybody finds their moment and
not everybody's supposed to
be number one but if you're
destined to be number 87,000
I'd rather you be 87,000
than 843 million.
Are you able to
come into, thank you.
- [DRock] No.
- [Gary] No?
("Victory" by OCD Mosh &amp; Twist)
- [Gary] I think because what
I'm selling and pontificating
about is very, very human and
not demo or age or demographic,
you know, it's kind of,
it's really simple.
I'm not selling anything to
anybody other than showing
people and documenting how I'm
going about it and really what
I think I'm pressing is
legacy and self-awareness
and you know
recognizing that it's only one
at-bat and I think I'm pounding
home very tried-and-true
things that I believe in.
I think maybe that's, you know,
it's funny I'm yapping here
maybe that's
what's working for me.
I so believe, geez, I so
believe in what I'm saying.
You know?
I think that that resonates
with people of all ages.
Whether one agrees or disagrees,
I do think it's important for
people to feel like that
somebody's intent is in the
right place and I believe that
my intent is catching people's
attention because
it genuinely is.
My big payoff here is
the email thanking me.
Is the tweet of admiration that
I did something for them with
nothing in return and so I feel
guilt that people are giving me
their time and attention and
I don't take that for granted
and it's very important to me
that while there
watching my video or
listening to the podcast
that I bring them value.
And I think one of the ways
I bring value is I challenge and
hype people to actually do
something and a funny thing
happens when you
actually do shit.
Stuff starts happening and
I also think I'm a no
excuses kind of character.
I think something I've been
seeing a lot come through my
social media in the last month
is people saying whether through
watching my DailyVee vlog
or through an
interaction on Instagram,
they realize they
weren't working hard or
they weren't really applying
themselves or they were
complaining and I think people
are paying attention because
I think they're getting results
from consuming me and I think
that's the ultimate compliment.
I need a power supply with me.
- [Tyler] I know.
- 'Cause I'm really bad.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Zak] Yeah, I do.
- Okay.
- [Zak] I wasn't--
- No worries, no worries.
No worries.
I got your email, thank you.
I haven't been able
to address it yet.
I will.
I will soon.
Talk to you.
'Sup man, how you doing?
- [Alex] Good.
- [Gary] All well? You?
- [Alex] Yeah.
Question for you, are you
cool with me sitting in on the
(censored) meeting tomorrow?
- Yeah.
I'm cool with you sitting
in on anything, just ask.
(construction
noises drowns out Tyler)
("Victory" by OCD Mosh &amp; Twist)
- So, I'm gonna have dinner with
him and talk about his nonprofit
and his wife's business
so I'll see him soon.
- [Woman] Oh my God,
this is a dream come true.
(Gary and DRock laugh)
I am not even
fucking joking you.
I worked at LinkedIn actually.
- [Gary] No way.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- (inaudible).
I messaged you, too.
I'm like "Gary!"
Is this--
- [Gary] This is DRock.
- [DRock] It is.
- [Woman] Oh, my God, hi.
- [DRock] How are you?
Good to meet you.
- [Woman] Nice to meet you.
- [DRock] Likewise.
- My director sent
this video, he's like,
"Hey, just want to give advice.
"It was very inspirational."
And I was like, "You know this
is really great and I do give my
"all in everything I do but
"I think to be
successful it's all
"about your attitude
and your perspectives."
So I was like, "Can we implement
"a challenge where
there's no complaining?"
- Sure.
- Right?
Because it's like toxic
and it's like a cancer.
I hate using that analogy.
Like, I literally have to walk
away from people and in sales
it's so crucial to be
being positive--
- Of course.
- because like what you said.
The glass is gonna be
half empty, not half full.
- That's right.
- He was like,
"I really love that.
"I'm gonna run it by our senior
manager and leadership team."
I was like, "Cool, let's do it.
Let's fucking do it."
And I sent him your video.
- That's awesome, thank you.
- I was like,
"Gary said it best."
- (laughs) Thank you.
- "Negativity is
louder than positivity."
- It is unfortunately.
- Yeah.
- It is.
- I know it is.
- I'm glad we ran
into each other.
- I know. I can't
believe I met you.
Oh my God.
I met GaryVee today.
- It happened.
And DRock.
- Dream come true.
(DRock laughs)
(laughter)
- Thank you.
- Thanks for the love.
- [Gary] Take care.
- Thank you.
You're doing your job.
- Thank you. Bye.
- [DRock] Bye.
- [Woman] Bye.
Nice to meet you.
- [DRock] You too.
- [Gary] Is that a
dog in the wild?
Dog, I found you.
(laughs)
- Give me a hug, brother.
- How are you?
- I need to talk
to you right now.
- What are you, you're here?
- Yeah. Russian restaurant.
- I know, I've been
here multiple times.
- Exactly, yes.
- What are you doing?
- You know what?
Can you come in?
- Yeah.
- Nick is there.
He want to (inaudible) tomorrow.
- Oh yeah? Yeah. Yeah.
- DRock, you need to film this.
- Oh my God!
Today.
- [Gary] It's amazing.
- A little Wall
Street Journal article.
- I saw. I heard it, I heard it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] All well?
- Incredible, yeah.
- Yeah,--
- Max is flying in and we're
recruiting. Max, me and two
guys on my team.
- So, it's clicking?
- It's awesome.
- I love the universe.
- It's the best thing ever, man.
- Good. Alright.
That was a super weird amount
of stuff going on
a quick second.
I'm glad you're around, DRock.
And, and, they're family.
They'll help us, they'll help
us get, you know, higher talent.
They're family.
Okay, sounds good.
Goin' inside.
Got three more meetings but
I'm gonna send you home, DRock.
I'll try to do a Snapchat for
you, you can use at the end of
this or you can end with
me going to the Regency.
This was a good one.
Good fuckin' day.
(light music)